[Music]
i'm patrick bailey of your host to
valuetainment weekend we've heard this
word before
born again many times this word born
again is used in a christian
denomination church which means a person
who's committed a lot of sins in the
past they come to a point where they're
so
unhappy frustrated just a lot of
challenges in life
and they make a decision to have a
spiritual
rebirth so they're born again they're
spiritually
born again they're a new person and it's
a regeneration a new life
new opportunity new chance second chance
at life
that's the phrase born again we've heard
many times before and i believe as an
entrepreneur most entrepreneurs are
amateur entrepreneurs
and i've been one before so an amateur
entrepreneur is very casual they're
winging it
it's more wishful thinking they're
hoping it works
they're hoping they get lucky and land
that big sale or that big partner or
that
big agent or big recruiter or someone
that's going to come on board and all of
a sudden
boom a 180 take place in their business
and they're wondering how come this
isn't happening to me here's why
every amateur entrepreneur every single
one of us is going to get to a breaking
point
and when you hit this wall at this wall
when we all hit
few things happen everybody who hits
this wall has two choices
95 say they become a victim they blame
they walk away
it isn't for me i can't do they quit
five percent
is so frustrated it's so limited
they're so annoyed that they make a
decision and they become a born-again
entrepreneur as if this is their first
day they became an entrepreneur but
they're not an amateur entrepreneur
anymore
they are a professional entrepreneur
treating it like a professional
new decisions new disciplines new work
ethic
new hunger factor new desire new clear
defined purpose
new goals and everybody says what
happened to this guy here
you've changed people don't recognize
you anymore people don't recognize your
eyes anymore
your relationships with people that are
growing gets better
your relationship with people who want
to improve you start attracting them
you know how come these people are
attracted to me because they can tell in
your
eyes you hit the wall you made a
decision
you didn't quit like most people do you
stuck around
you became a born-again entrepreneur and
everything
in your business changes but until you
don't make that decision which in latin
means
cut away from the old you if you don't
make that decision
the results are going to be the same and
we're coming to the end of the year
this will be the perfect time for you to
sit down and say i am
so sick of plain small
in my life that i'm going to become a
born-again entrepreneur
and start experiencing new things based
on my new habits
taking responsibility for my actions
what i need to do to improve
and you'll see new results new
experiences everything just changing
for you it's my message of the week gm
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel and comment on the bottom thanks
for watching
i'd like to play uh nocturne in c sharp
minor for you maybe you recognize her
from the movie
um the pianist if you remember that
movie
never said i was gonna play for you said
i wanted to play song for you
hope you enjoyed this song as much as i
enjoy the song